Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to look at
NVIDIA’s new AI research work which,
as they say allows us to paint with words.
So, let’s see. Yes, this runs a generative
denoising process, or in other words, it
starts out from a bunch of noise, and over time,
uses our text prompt to rearrange it into an image
that we described. Great. Then, it subjects these
coarse images to a super resolution technique,
which means that in goes this coarse image, and
out comes an image with so much more detail.
And hence, can generate images of this quality.
Now, wait a minute. We are experienced Fellow
Scholars over here, so we know that OpenAI’s
DALL-E 2 can do this. And Google’s Imagen
can do this. The free and open source stable
diffusion can also do this. We have a number of
papers that can pull this off really well. So,
is NVIDIA a little late to the party? Why
publish this paper? What is new here? Well,
let’s push it to its limits through 3 really
fun experiments and find out together.
One, it gives us something that many of us Fellow
Scholars desire. And that is, of course, more
control over the synthesized images! For instance,
here, we wish to create an image of boxing
squirrels. Yes, you heard it right. But wait, here
is the more granular control part: we can draw
exactly where each squirrel and the boxing gloves
go. And, there we go! Loving it. Or, if we wish
to create a rabbit who is also a magician, we can
also specify that it should stand on clouds, and
we noted that it should cast a fireball. Now we
can tell it where exactly that fireball should go.
Two, it also follows our instructions really well
when it comes to requesting styles as well. We can
ask it to paint this penguin in the style of many
famous artists, with really cool results. However,
sometimes just saying which artist we are
looking for is not that helpful. You know,
which phase of the artist are we talking about?
Or which particular work should it be based on?
And hold on to your papers, because this
can even help out when our words fail us.
How? Well, in this case, we can also use an
image instead. We can still add a text prompt,
and it will create the new image in the style
of this one. This is especially useful in cases
when we have a style in mind that is really
hard to explain. I love this one. So cool!
Three, so how does it compare to the usual
suspects? Well, let’s have a look at some
teapots. Of course, to the surprise of no one,
Stable Diffusion and DALL-E 2 are both capable
of this task, however, look. We did not get a
painting of a panda. And, with the new technique,
look at that! Oh yes! Once again, it follows our
instructions better. Now note that text to image
AIs are not easy to evaluate as all models
can generate a ton of different images for
the same prompt. However, further comparisons
reveal that there indeed is a pattern here.
Now, have you noticed? There is a
pattern in this video too. I keep
saying that this new technique
follows our instructions better,
so here is the most important question.
Why? How is all this wizardry possible?
Well, this was one of my favorite parts of the
paper. Have a look at this. The authors claim
that as the classical text to image AIs start
out from noise, they follow our prompt closely,
however, later on in the image synthesis
process, not so much. If we change the
prompt for the last few percentage
of the noise diffusion process, look.
Ouch! It completely ignores it. And here comes the
best part: the authors trained multiple separate
denoiser networks that are suited to different
parts of the generation process. Hence, yes,
you guessed it right, these can follow our
instructions better throughout later parts
of the image generation process, and
thus, give us better artistic control.
Now I am sure that the next generation of text
to image AIs are going to be even more powerful
two more papers down the line, but this concept
may live on to improve even these subsequent
versions. I am very excited to see if this will
really be the case. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!